well here's kind of an amazing story so
the American Academy of Pediatrics which
if you've got kids you kind of trust
apparently
um has issued new guidance on Obesity
and you don't want to think that any
medical association exists to make money
for drug companies but you have to kind
of wonder in light of the American
Academy of Pediatrics as new guidelines
for childhood obesity now anyone who's
tried to lose weight we can speak to
this directly no stop eating a lot of
sugary food and you'll probably lose
weight but that's not the guidance
they're saying the kids as young as 13
years old should take weight loss
medication
and potentially undergo surgery for
children Dr Mark Siegel joins us tonight
to assess this hey doctor
Tucker this is the first time they've
put out guidelines on Obesity in 15
years with 15 million uh children from 2
to 19 obese uh but that's before the
pandemic and these guidelines do read
like panic and and you know me clinical
practice guidelines I don't follow
rigidly any clinical practice guidelines
period I don't doctor by the numbers you
know I listen to the patient I don't fat
Shame by the way I talk to patients I
listen to what they're sensitive to I
want to know what their concerns are are
you depressed why are you eating so much
are you sedentary guess what the
pandemic did took kids away from schools
where they had nutrition programs locked
them down where they lie on the couch
all day no exercise you're not allowed
to go out well guess what now happens
they're burgeoning in weight so what do
they do now they need jerk a solution I
know we'll give you a pill oh that
doesn't work we'll do surgery that might
have long-term complications to it why
don't we do that well I I have a
prescription instead of all of that I
want to acknowledge knowledge that and I
want to go back to the beginning I have
my own guidelines Dr Siegel's guidelines
you introduce vegetables to your diet
you introduce it to your kids diet you
take you go on a walk you take your kid
on a walk you have them exercise you
ride a bike you have them ride a bike
and then you challenge them at the end
of the night Tucker you say watch Tucker
Carlson tonight and see if it challenges
your brain Tucker
I mean getting rid of pizza and Oreos
speaking for myself I do love I mean
that kind of goes a long way like why
not just say that
it does and exercise yeah Dr Mark Siegel
thank you